now water and sewage firms in England
have issued a public apology for not
acting quickly enough on sewage spills
according to the environment agency
untreated sewage was pumped into
England's rivers and seized more than
300 000 times last year an average of
824 per day with the industry body water
UK has today promised to spend 10
billion pounds on what it claims will be
the biggest modernization of the sewers
since the Victorian era or joining me
now is the chair of water UK the former
cabinet minister Ruth Kelly Ruth Kelly
welcome to you this has been known about
for years why has it taken so long for
the industry to apologize
yeah thank you thank you very much for
inviting me here today it's good to be
on and let's take a step back the first
thing I'm here to do today is to say
sorry I've been very chastened by
listening to the public by hearing the
views of people I understand we
understand it's a water industry how
upset and angry people are about
untreated sewage going into rivers and
onto our beaches and we are determined
to put that right so today we're
announcing a tripling of the level of
investment into tackling spills into
rivers and onto beaches and you're right
to say why has it taken them so long we
we get it we should have acted sooner
it's only in the last few years in fact
and that we've had the data to really
see the extent of this problem but we
are absolutely determined now to put
that right
is this new money this 10 billion pounds
or is this money that the industry would
have had to have put up anyway given
that the government announced a storm
overflows reduction uh scheme in August
last year
this is new money that goes on top of
the 3 billion that's already been
pledged to tackle this issue this is
money which of course will feed through
to the government's overall Target we
want to go as fast as we possibly can to
try and reduce the number of spills
however we think that 10 billion pounds
in a five-year period is the maximum
physical capacity of the sector to make
these changes so you're talking about
hiring construction
experts you're talking about scientists
you're talking about engineers being
employed to build huge big sewage
overflow tanks the size of Olympic
swimming pools thousands of these
underground across the country so we
don't think we can do it faster than
this but we're determined to make every
effort we can to stop putting this
problem right and where's the money
going to come from shareholders or
customers
well what we're doing is we're asking
shareholders to to put down a huge down
payment multi-billion pound down payment
uh to start putting this problem right
it's the biggest transformation project
in the water industry's history since
the Victorian times the way the system
works is that over the lifetime of the
asset customers do pay that money back
in in modest increases in their bills
over the last 10 years I think it's
important to remember that that real
water bills have fallen for the average
customer and our research shows us that
customers on the whole are prepared to
pay a little bit more to see this in
source of investment undertaken but
customers will be asking why on Earth
should they be having to put their hand
in their pocket when the water industry
paid out 1.4 billion pounds in dividends
last year
well I think as a sign of the
seriousness with which the water
companies are taking at this issue and
all water company CEOs have have come
together and they've said they're not
going to pay a single penny for instance
on bonuses out of customer funds this
year half of them the water and sewage
companies across England and Wales are
waving their bonus entirely on dividends
I don't quite recognize the the picture
that you're painting on dividends last
year three of the of the 10 water and
sewage companies uh actually made a loss
and the average return across the sector
was less than less than four percent now
that's not that much more than you'd get
if you if they just put it in Bank in
the bank on on deposit so so we do need
to attract hundreds of billions of
investment over the coming decades into
the sector we have to compete against
other utility companies the energy
companies the airports the rail sector
we have to compete for this money so
it's right that at dividend ought to be
paid but as I say the dividends have
been at fairly low levels compared to
other sectors even after this investment
sewage spills may still be in the 100
thousands I mean why is it ever
acceptable for untreated sewage to enter
waterways
yeah I mean it's right it's a it's a
really horrible relic of the past to see
untreated sewage um go into into the
waterways you never would have built a
system from scratch today uh in in that
way um it's you know hard to understand
why why water from bathrooms and
kitchens is mingled with with fresh
groundwater and rain water and all
treated together you wouldn't design a
system like that but that is the system
we've got
and it is going to take time to put that
right now even with billions of pounds
of investment if you look at the London
super uh sewer as an example four
billion pounds just just putting into
the Thames Water Area to treat uh to
treat London's sewage that doesn't
eliminate leaks spills completely but
they do become extremely limited
um and you know the the harm that it's
caused is is completely eliminated so um
we won't get to a situation where
they're all disappear disappear but we
are all going to make a dramatic impact
on the harm caused by spills
presumably uh this investment is not
going to be equally spread across the
country I mean somewhere like United
Utilities in the Northwest I mean their
sewage spill level is about four or five
times the rate of somewhere like
Southern water in the south of England
yeah you're right the infrastructure is
different in different parts of the
country and more work needs to be done
in some areas than others as a water
sector we're saying holders to account
for the Investments that we make and we
want to do this in in two ways first by
publishing a detailed investment plan
there are 15
000 over spills in this country
overflows that lead to spills we want to
publish an investment plan which spill
overflow spill by overflow spill says
exactly what's going to happen when the
money is going to be invested and what
the result of that is going to be so
that people will be able to see that
secondly by this time next year we're
saying to people you know log on we're
going to have a single Central data Hub
you can log on you can you can check to
for your locality see exactly if any
discharges have been made and what
discharges have been made and decide
whether you want to go bathing at that
time so real accountability and
transparency around the level of
discharges across the country
parting uh thought from me if you would
please I mean water privatization has
led to 160 billion pounds worth of
investment as she said water bills are
far lower in the UK or in England and
Wales than they are in countries where
the state operates the water system why
is it do you think so many people favor
renationalization
well sometimes I think renationalization
is seen as free money but obviously it's
it's not and I mean I've sat in the
treasury as a treasury Minister and I've
sat on the other side of the table as
well where people come to bids for
investment and I know how difficult it
would be under a nationalized sector uh
for for to to really get the investment
that's so desperately needed when you're
competing against investment in
hospitals and in schools so it's not a
you know a a free win scenario as it
were being being nationalized that money
has to come from somewhere and what
we're saying is that shareholders stand
ready to invest hundreds of billions of
pounds in the water sector to to really
improve it
all right Ruth Kelly gotta leave it
there good to see you this morning thank
you
thank you bit of breaking news to bring
you a transgender butcher has pleaded
guilty to abducting a schoolgirl in the
Scottish borders and taking her home to
repeatedly sexually abuse her our
Scotland correspondent Connor Gillies is
Edinburgh High Court and has more corner
yeah this is a highly distressing case
that unfolded in the Scottish borders in
February of this year and it centers
around someone who is referred to as a
man inside the court building here in
the last few minutes A Man known as
Andrew Miller
but he also refers to himself as Amy
George the court heard that he is in the
process of transitioning to a woman at
this stage now this is important because
in February of this year we have learned
that this person while identifying as
Amy George while dressed as a woman
lured a schoolgirl into his car in the
Scottish borders while she was walking
home one Sunday evening
and got into the car the girl thought
that it was a safe haven given this
person was dressed as a woman there were
no buses in the area her phone we heard
in the court was out of battery so she
got into that vehicle and it quickly
descended into one of the most uh
dangerous crimes that the courtroom has
heard in quite a while this girl who of
course her anonymity must be protected
through this so details we have to be
careful about what we can see she was
taken back to the property of Amy George
Andrew Miller
locked in the bedroom and repeatedly
sexually assaulted the court heard some
pretty distressing details that we
cannot report for legal reasons taste
and decency clearly being one of them
but we heard that this girl made a brave
attempt to flee the scene and was
successful in that attempt after a great
many hours uh Andrew Miller Amy George
had fallen asleep the girl escaped that
room and managed to phone 999 the police
clearly descended on that property
within minutes and she was saved the
court heard that police said that her
fear was palpable now the court heard
some details around the person appearing
in the dock via video link today we
understand that at the time they were
identifying as a woman but when they
appeared in the police station they said
it would be easier to identify as a man
their gender assigned at Birth they are
currently in the process we understand
of trans as well the detail is still
unfolding here the hearing is continuing
but this is pretty distressing content
emerging of a school girl a young girl
who was abducted from a street lured
into a vehicle and repeatedly sexually
assaulted at the hands of a local
businessman who was a butcher
okay thanks Connor
now earlier in the week we reported how
Vice media the digital news startup had
file for bankruptcy protection ahead of
it being acquired by its creditors will
apply to Vice and some other titles such
as BuzzFeed have highlighted the
difficulties for digital startups but
older established titles have also faced
challenges in changing their business
model to embrace digital one of them is
the enemy founded 71 years ago which
went online only in 2018 joining me now
is Holly Bishop she's Chief Operating
and Commercial officer at nme networks
Holly welcome to you I mean um you went
free in 2015 and then closed the print
edition in in 2018 has the enemy traded
since then
so I think if you look at enemy as a
brand one of the most exciting you know
takeouts from from the brand is that we
are a 70 year old youth brand which is
unique in itself in 2023 we have this
incredible Legacy behind us which
continues to inspire us day to day but
you know we don't allow ourselves to be
absorbed too much by the past and you
know enemy
as a brand has always been at the
Forefront of change and Innovation you
know whether that's through our
journalistic you know tastes and
surfacing of new music and new genres
and even as you mentioned you know as we
evolved into new platforms so you know
we were one of the early adopters of.com
in 96 and then you know moving into
various iterations of a print product
and you know most recently the free
sheep model and you know if we look at
the free sheet proposition it definitely
served a purpose for the brand in terms
of you know driving that inclusivity and
representing music as it is today and
and the tastes of you know today's
Millennial and gen Z audiences you know
tribalism has been eroded and actually
that free sheet proposition allowed us
to you know invite you know new genres
of music and really broaden the output
of of the brand and not just for music
you know as we start to secure you know
a future for the brand it was about
diversification and you know that's
about bringing new verticals in you know
music is at the intersection of all of
pop culture and so yeah I looked at the
website yesterday I mean music's only
part of it there's lots about films and
gaming and all sorts yeah definitely so
you know film TV gaming are you know
some of the largest uh sections of the
website and definitely if you look at an
audience now today you know music fans
are film fans our gaming fans you know
they are one and the same and so to come
to us as a you know as an authentic
voice that has been here for 70 years
and be able to deliver content in a you
know across the platforms that our
audience are consuming them but in new
verticals you know that's that's great
for us and great for our audience what
do we know about your customers and your
audience I mean how much use do you make
of data
I think you know data plays A Part but
also you know we are
we really double down on what we know we
do best which is our position of
Discovery you know for the last seven 70
years we have really championed emerging
music and this is something that is very
much our position of strength and
something that you know we stand by and
we are committed to in the long term and
I think you know we will always
celebrate the icons of course but it's
our support of you know the underground
and championing that emerging talent
that gives us a real point of difference
do you think I mean I used to read it
religiously uh when I was younger um The
Golden Era sort of Stuart mcconey and
Stephen Wells writing for the enemy have
you ever got plans to digitize some of
that old print uh stuff and put it up
online
I think there's there's definitely a
place to bring some of the old into the
new and actually recently we worked on a
commercial partnership with Bose
um you know a significant industry
leader in the audio space and we
resurfaced the iconic c-series mixtapes
and uh c86 I still got it yeah exactly
so we uh brought that back and
reimagined it for a 2023 audience and
you know that was a really exciting
project and for all parties really it
was an opportunity for us to surface
emerging Talent which is obviously what
we're great at but also provide
opportunities for that talent to connect
with audiences in many different ways so
yes we put the mixtape on all the
digital platforms that didn't exist back
in 86 but we also created a cassette and
pressed the vinyl for it and gave six
artists the chance to play on stage at
South by Southwest in Austin and Texas
so many ways that you know Brands fans
musicians can connect with the brand
um that you know keep us relevant and
keep us young very good Holly got to
leave it there I'm afraid good to see
you this morning thank you
[Music]
well after a strong finish on Wall
Street last night on hopes of a deal to
raise the U.S debt ceiling Equity
markets in the Asia Pacific region had a
solid session overnight the Nikkei in
Tokyo hit a fresh 20-month high up
nearly one and three quarter percent
well in Europe markets are also largely
in positive territory this morning
here's the current picture all the main
indices up by at least around half of
one percent or more here in London on a
busy day for company results the ftse
100 is also positive territory up just
over half of one percent the leading
Blue Chip Gainer right now is convatec
that's the medical devices a medical
equipment supplier the shares up there
three and three quarter percent
following a trading update meanwhile the
exhibitions and events group Informer it
shows ahead by just over two percent
today and acquisition it's announced has
been well received on the downside
Burberry is off by nearly six and a half
percent right now that's on news of a
quarterly drop in sales in the United
States but BT group is just about the
leading Faller off by nearly seven
percent on its results outside the ftse
100 again a really busy day for company
results today Premier Foods that's the
Mr Kipling maker you can see on the
screen there they're up by three and a
half percent the biggest uh mid-cap
Gainer right now though is Aston Martin
Lagonda the shares ahead there by some
13 and that's on use of a 234 million
pound investment by the Chinese car
maker Julie that will see the owner of
lotus become the company's third largest
shareholder meanwhile the house Builder
history its Shares are up by some three
and a quarter percent that's on an
upbeat trading update
on the front Exchange Market as well
those debt ceiling talks have given the
U.S dollar a bit of lead in its pencil
this morning Sterling is off by nearly
half of one percent against the
Greenback uh the euro is also down by
third one percent against the dollar
meanwhile The single currency itself is
uh ahead against Sterling by nearly a
sixth of one percent right now on the
Old Market so commodity markets yeah the
oil price rallied yesterday on news of
higher than expected crude inventories
today about a crude Brent crude will set
you back
76.53 cents a barrel that's off little
over half of one percent on the session
well joining me this morning is someone
Ahmed Global head of macro and strategic
asset allocation at Fidelity
International salmon great to see you
this morning
um looking at your latest uh big Global
calls you still think uh risks are very
much to the downside on the on GDP
forecast why is that
uh good morning Ian uh definitely I
think uh we are basically focused on
this slow moving credit crunch which is
uh you know building up in the
background of course we've had a lot of
tightening uh since last year uh that
then started to transform into these
banking stresses we saw in the US and if
you look at the lending survey data uh
what we are seeing is that uh that banks
are increasingly tightening lending
standards and that is consistent with
some kind of a concrete contraction
going forward and that's underpinning or
our forecast of downside risk to GDP
growth as these stresses come through uh
in a slow moving fashion but still uh uh
in in an environment where credit
availability starts to drop and that's
where the downside risk is coming from
someone how is that informing your asset
allocations right now because obviously
what you've just told me it feels like
there's a bit of a disconnect with some
Equity markets right now
and yes there is a disconnect between
equity markets and more markets as well
so the bond markets are much more I
would say worried you see Cuts being
priced in uh across the board uh and now
those cuts don't come for free in the
sense like there has to be environment
which justifies the key central banks to
Pivot and and that pivot will
potentially come through if growth is
under pressure and that will have impact
on earnings so that disconnect between
equity and bond market is quite a sharp
one and that's why we have become more
defensive on equities at the top down
level uh even though we maintain a
stance that em will probably do better
than develop markets uh but overall we
are concerned that Equity Market
valuations are not capturing these kind
of downside risks which are slower
moving in the pipeline
someone what about this talk about the
U.S debt ceiling I mean markets seem to
be taking a fairly sanguine approach
towards this uh the danger of a U.S debt
defaults out of the way now
um so as we know that uh these kind of
issues have happened many times over the
recent past and ultimately the
resolution comes through so the Market's
view is that you know they don't want to
be caught out uh by uh by ultimate
resolution uh so that's one of the
reasons why this uh this this Comfort is
still there but we do think that this
will go to the wire you will have
day-to-day news flow around it but uh uh
but this will go to the wire because of
the polarization uh which is uh
currently in place in in Washington uh
and then at some point for a very short
period of time uh hopefully uh that
markets may have to get involved and put
pressure on policy makers to get to a
resolution so this can get uh tricky as
we move towards June because uh if this
is not raised then the U.S government
will run out of money uh by mid-june
now going back to your Global macro
Outlook the one uh part of the world
that you are reasonably optimistic for
is is Japan obviously we've had some
tremendous uh company results out of
Japan lately the Nikkei is on an
absolute tear for how long is that
sustainable do you think
we think there is structural
underpinning now uh uh supporting Japan
because it's a weird value market uh
first and foremost uh uh and and an
environment where real rates are
positive uh we do think that value style
can do better but in terms of Japan
itself you've had a lot of structural
development in terms of improving
corporate governance standards uh that
has helped a lot and then these
companies are starting to innovate uh
and and and and and and you get bang for
buck from a valuation perspective so
from a structural perspective we are
positive in Japan and the fact that real
positive real rates will help from a
value style uh uh uh Dimension as well
it's a really interesting point you make
because over the last decade or so all
of the focus has been on the Emerging
Markets such as China to a lesser extent
India perhaps Japan often get gets
overlooked by Global Investors do you
think it's back in the shop window again
now do you hear people talking about
Japan more
yes certainly your client base is more
and more queries we are getting on Japan
because ultimately International
investors are underway Japan from a
structural perspective and then as uh
U.S Equity Market starts to look more
expensive given the issues we discussed
uh uh there is this you know
reallocation uh force uh in play uh
which is basically uh benefiting Japan
from from a capital demand perspective
as well but of course uh there is under
underlying Improvement uh in the market
and the governance standards as well
which is helping uh uh so there is I
think it's a sweet spot for more demand
and Supply perspective
all right Simon we have to leave it
there it's good to see you again this
morning thanks for joining me
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live
we're going to be hearing from
advertising week Europe as Executives
discuss the impact of AI on the industry
stay with us
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back this week is advertising
week Europe the annual get-together of
the great and good of the advertising
and marketing world and us with so many
other indices right now technology is at
the heart of the discussions but the
organizers have honored some surprising
evidence about the extent to which
senior leaders at UK businesses are
failing to engage with artificial
intelligence joining me now is Ruth
Mortimer Global president of advertising
week Europe welcome to you Ruth what
have you found
so one of the really interesting things
we've found is just how big the
disconnect is between senior employees
at companies and more Junior employees
what we're seeing is that senior and
Senior leaders don't really appreciate
either the opportunities or the threats
that AI can bring to their businesses
well the truth is their workers are
already using AI
are we talking about just the
advertising and marketing sectors or
business more broadly
no business more broadly we looked
specifically at the advertising and
creative sectors but we actually looked
right across all industries from
medicine through to construction and the
picture is the same pretty much
everywhere
one of the things that uh you found that
interested me is that a lot of people
don't want to tell their manager that
they've been using AIS is that because
it's kind of associated with cutting
Corners in some way
I think traditionally the way we've
talked about AI is that it's going to
remove human jobs that's one of the
things that's been associated with we
haven't talked so much about the
creative opportunities and what it can
add to people's jobs so I think lots of
workers are a little bit nervous that if
they would say to their manager they're
using AI that that could actually result
in their own job being insecure I mean I
know from previous conversations that
use of generative AI in particular is is
really widespread now but two-thirds of
companies don't even have a policy and
on AI that's quite surprising isn't it
it really is and you know what I think
that's that's part of the reason for the
disconnect
um more senior leaders don't appreciate
that they need to have a policy and
therefore workers who are already using
AI don't know how to have the
conversations with their bosses about
what they should be doing with it and
what they shouldn't because there's
really significant issues particularly
with intellectual property that you
really need to be educated on
absolutely so tell me about the mood
more broadly in the uh in the industry
right now I've been to the advertising
week your event myself in the past it's
always very very Buzzy people feeling
fairly good about the world right now
yeah look I think there's I think
there's a mix of different things
preoccupying people you mentioned AI I
think the cost of living crisis is
weighing heavily on people's minds we
have big Brands here today like Pepsi
and just eat having really hard hitting
conversations about how they can be
responsible and support consumers in
this time and how that needs to be an
industry-wide
um
industry-wide initiative to really make
an impact because that is big news but
yes this is the creative industry so
along with um issues always come
opportunities and people are here
talking today about ways in which even
the cost of living crisis can be used to
help develop more sustainable Logistics
more sustainable pipelines rethink The
Way businesses work so yes still very
Buzzy well that's good to hear now this
is actually the first time you've run
this event advertising week itself
changed hands last summer we've brought
by a business called Emerald holding has
that changed really the way that you go
about your business
I can I think for us what it just means
is
um access to a bigger support network
for us Emerald has lots of businesses in
different areas such as retail design
which are really complementary to us so
hopefully you're just going to see us
get bigger and bigger and better
all right good to see you this morning
Ruth thanks very much for joining me
enjoy the rest of the week thank you
thanks so much Ian
now if you get a chance check out my
piece on the Sky News website on
accusations at supermarkets or
profiteering from inflation so-called
greed inflation if you click on the QR
code right now on your screen that will
take you to that article to have a look
at that if you can
now earlier this week the employee
engagement platform reward Gateway
agreed to a takeover by the French
prepaid vouchers company in red in a
deal that values it at 1.15 billion
pounds will reward Gateway which was
founded in 2006 enables employers to
build engagement with their employees
via staff discount schemes rewards and
surveys it's four thousand clients
around the world include marks and
Spencer Vodafone Travis Perkins Heineken
and Samsung will joining me now is Nick
Burns he's chief executive of reward
Gateway Nick welcome to you you
previously owned by private Equity Funds
were they looking to sell or did this
approach come as a bolt from the blue as
it were morning and thank you for
inviting me on a bit of a bolt from the
blue is the uh is the answer you you
know what it's like in with private
Equity it's normally a three to five
year gig and um this was about one and a
half years so the approach was made but
uh it was the right fit okay you've got
650 employees around the world including
in the UK what will this mean for them
great opportunity uh the main reason for
that is the Eden red
platform across 45 countries and we're
in Three uh four actually if you if you
include our Servicing Center in Bulgaria
so the opportunities for our people to
perhaps spread their wings and maybe go
and work in other countries around the
world uh will be fantastic for those who
have the ambition and the desire to want
to do so and what will you be able to do
as part of a larger group
it's that for our people but for uh our
platform which already operates on a
global stage but you know we've got
boots on the ground in in those three or
four countries even red have them
physical presence in 45 countries
so the platform can now travel to 45
countries and and access
not just uh tens or even hundreds of
thousands of of employees but
but millions of employees around the
world now and and that's
that's a real game changer and something
I think we'll all be really proud of uh
over the over the coming years yeah now
Employee Engagement is quite a Hot Topic
right now because staff retention is
such a big issue what are the sort of
trends that you're seeing right now
across the industry
well of course cost of living is a big
one it's affecting employees right
across the world
and the immediacy of uh the type of
employee benefits that we offer through
our platform in particular uh discounts
start uh discounts if people you know
want to buy their groceries or shopping
or whatever it may be
people who want to maybe buy some
technology uh
um you know get themselves a new Sky
glass TV or whatever it might be right
the immediacy to help them financially
there's a big pressure on employers now
to try and make that happen and and the
reward Gateway platform and others are
really helping I think there to help
employees just take some of this thing
out of of cost of living I mean I reeled
off some of the customers that you have
early on I mean a lot of them are big
multinationals how low down the sort of
corporate food chain that's a great
question and that's a great question
because very often it's the the bigger
companies the Enterprise companies who
perhaps can uh you know let their
employees get access to these platforms
about 18 months ago we we developed a
slightly different angle to to the
platform to give access to an
organization with maybe three or four
employees right give them that same
benefit if you like that the bigger
codes can can have so we learned in the
big companies and then we've taken it
further down and it has been
unbelievably successful because why
should you not get the benefit of that
if you're a part of a company with 10
people as opposed to being part of a
company with a thousand or ten thousand
people and it's just it's just grown so
quickly over the last 12 months or so
what's the future for the industry in
terms of I mean if I think about the way
that Sky operates as an employer I mean
we have an engagement uh platform which
is pretty comprehensive but then if I
want to look at how my pension is doing
it's outsourced to someone else entirely
can you see those sort of things coming
together in the future yeah
um I mean you've got a great engagement
platform I have to tell you the
um
yeah they're linking right so so
employee benefits traditionally have
been around Pension funds uh maybe
medical plans particularly in the US
but these are plans that people think
longer term about but human beings now
we want things now don't we uh it's more
immediate and getting a blend between
the immediate desire for something
but thinking long term as well bringing
the two together
um that's happening now actually uh and
indeed through our platform we're now
connecting into all the pension fund
platforms so that you have one place you
can go to to think about your one life
uh and um that's going to gather real
momentum I think fascinating Nick good
to see you this morning thank you thank
you very much
so we can bring you the Prime Minister
Rishi sunak has just arrived in
Hiroshima in Japan for the G7 Summit
obviously global leaders are heading
there right now Joe Biden I think is uh
if he's not already there he's certainly
on his way and the Prime Minister will
be meeting the Japanese prime minister
in a couple of hours from now looks a
bit drizzly over there in Hiroshima
gotta say
and we have a bit more breaking news to
uh bring here it's busy morning isn't it
police in New Zealand have arrested
uncharged a man in connection with a
hostile fire that killed at least six
people you have seen these uh pictures
from earlier the week this horrendous
hostile fire a man has been charged in
connection with that we'll bring you
more on that as soon as we have it here
on Sky News
still to come here on Ian King live
investec the 10th largest bank in the UK
has reported a big jump in profits today
I'll be speaking next to its chief
executive don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
and I'm Skye's Chief north of England
correspondent
there is now a mandatory evacuation for
this street for many people Harvey is
far from over
Christchurch has been changed Forever by
what happened here there was a river of
blood coming out of the mosque
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of America's opioid
crisis I've reported from around the
world and around the UK are you trying
to run me over sir Philip no go away
look like it sir
Joe Biden knows the celebrations are
over and this is a country in crisis
[Music]
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
Ida has certainly left its mark on New
Orleans it just feels heartbreaking
do you regret the Tweet Gary there's no
sign publicly at least of either side
being willing to give ground
how do you reassure the public
that all of these mistakes wouldn't be
made again
thank you
[Music]
foreign
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
[Music]
invest in your future Sky News Financial
reports sponsored by interactive
investor
welcome back investec the 10th biggest
bank in the UK and the fifth largest in
South Africa today hired higher Global
interest rates and Loan growth after
reporting an adjusted operating profit
of 835.9 million pounds for the year to
the end of March that was up nearly 22
on the same period a year ago well the
bank famous of course for its zebra logo
said the Improvement had come despite an
increase of more than 11 in its costs
and some tough economic conditions
around the world and particularly in
South Africa itself for joining me now
live from Johannesburg is investex group
chief executive Vani Titi Farney good to
see you again
um tell me about the situation running
in and good to be here
tell me about the situation in South
Africa you've got unemployment running
at I think 32 inflation still seven
percent it must be very difficult
running a bank to that sort of
macroeconomic backdrop
you correct Ian that the macro backdrop
is quite challenging
um we've had load shedding
um for the last 15 years or so and it
has been particularly severe over the
last uh years so economic growth has
been revised down from about 1.2 percent
to uh about 0.2 percent uh so it's a
tough uh macroeconomic backdrop but our
clients are in the high net worth space
in the high net income space and in the
corporate space and those clients have
been quite resilient in this period
hence we've been able to grow our
profits in the bank in South Africa by
22 and by just under two percent uh on
the wealth side of our business but it
is a tough macro environment
impairments During the period were up
from 28 to 80 million pounds most of
that was in the UK what sort of areas
are you seeing impairments Rising
this was expected of course Ian given
the uh pressure on on a clients uh given
the levels of interest rates so we
expected that that would increase
um in the UK we saw impairments
increased to a uh a credit loss ratio of
about 37 basis points which is uh at the
upper end over through the cycle range
of 30 to 40 basis points we have a
number of portfolios as an example we
have an asset Finance portfolio where
you would have smaller exposure smaller
companies those would generally feel a
bit more pressure in a time like this
but we are not seeing any pressure that
is beyond what we would have expected
given the deterioration in the economic
Outlook okay finally just to explain
there was a noise that you might have
heard there in the background other
viewers are currently looking at some
pictures of the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak who's arrived in Hiroshima for the
G7 Summit with his wife there um finally
since we last spoke you've announced
plans to merge investec wealth with
rough bones what was the thinking behind
that transaction
in the wealth management space scale is
important
um red bones have about 60 billion of
funds under management and
administration we have about 40 billion
and it was really important for us to
create through the combination uh the
UK's leading dfm player and and with
that we have the scale to grow we can
invest in technology we can attract the
best people and we can increase the
diversity of our offering to our clients
secondly we will be able to offer
banking products at the high net event
to uh clients of the enlarged red bones
group and equally
um uh private banking and other banking
clients will be able to access wealth
services and products from rathbones so
we've styled it as a strategic Alliance
we will be a 40
shareholder and we are in it for the
long term uh with ref bones really
excited about what the dfm market offers
in the UK yes you're obviously going to
be the biggest shareholder in rathbones
after this is will you ultimately look
to grow that stake or will you sell it
at some point
look we are a long-term shareholder and
we go into it with the intention of
staying in for the long term we will
support the management in the business
we've worked with them over the last six
months or so to try and identify areas
where we can work together and we can
support them where we can have the
benefits of scale so a long-term
shareholder at any rate in the short
term we've also committed not to
increase our stake but we would not be a
seller we are a long-term uh strategic
holder of the stake and we are in
partnership with them with respect to
our ability to offer their wealth
products to our clients and similarly
for us at the higher networks to offer
our banking products to the clients of
the enlarged group
and uh to what extent do you expect to
see client numbers growing over the next
12 months
volatility in the market the uncertainty
in the macro economy
um as as you know as we said today there
is a level of concern around Regional
and small banks in in the US there is
concern about the debt ceiling there
within the UK as you know over the last
uh six to 12 months there's been a high
degree of volatility interest rates
remain high the cost of living remains
high so clients are generally quite
um conservative at the moment so
hopefully as the the Outlook improves we
will see uh clients putting money to use
uh in in a much more positive way funny
great to see you again this morning
thanks for joining me a pleasure thank
you that's it from me I'm back at 10
o'clock tomorrow morning hope to see you
then thanks for joining me today
[Music]